quisiera comenzar preguntándole cómo
evalúa estas medidas cree que son
suficientes
Sí mira realmente felicitamos la medida
del parlamento japonés en aumentar la
edad mínima del consentimiento de Trece
a dieciséis años sabemos que estas
medidas son muy importantes para
proteger a las niñas a los niños a los
adolescentes que quizás por estar en una
edad muy temprana realmente no saben
distinguir si se trata una situación de
abuso o no en nivel internacional no
existe una edad mínima para el
consentimiento y hay que tener mucho
cuidado de no elevarla demasiado porque
también está en juego el tema de el
desarrollo progresivo de los
adolescentes y de las adolescentes a
consentir pero sin lugar a dudas el
comité de Derechos Humanos por ejemplo
ha dicho que Trece años es una edad muy
baja para consentir y en América Latina
por ejemplo la edad mínima está entre 14
y 16 años es suficiente Eso dependerá en
realidad de si el estado pone en
práctica medidas para llevar esta ley a
que se implementar es decir el hecho que
tengamos una ley que haya elevado la la
edad mínima del consentimiento No no es
no es no puede llegar a no ser
suficiente sino que toma las medidas
para por ejemplo para que los fiscales
estén entrenados sobre Cómo investigar
estos casos claro habrá que ver cómo se
implementa no bueno hablando de estos
avances no antes los fiscales tenían que
probar que los acusados habían utilizado
violencia intimidaciones ahora se aclara
no en la ley que todas absolutamente
todas las relaciones sexuales no
consensuadas son ilegales esto cree
usted que podría aumentar las denuncias
ante estos delitos digo porque muchas
veces ocurre que no son denunciados no
por distintos motivos miedo entre muchos
otros sí las víctimas de violencia
sexual tienen no no denunciar porque no
confiamos en el sistema de justicia en
general pero de hecho es un gran avance
que se haya modificado la definición de
violación sexual a que pasara a ser de
probar si hubo o no hubo fuerza de
probar si hubo o no hubo suficiente
resistencia a que simplemente la
ausencia del consentimiento es la que
Define el delito de violación sexual
Entonces esto ya lo dijo la corte
Europea de derechos humanos desde hace
20 años en un caso de una niña de 14
años que fue víctima de una violación y
llegó el caso precisamente la pregunta
fue la definición de la violación sexual
es ausencia de consentimiento o es
probar fuerza y el estándar claramente
es el que acaba de adoptar el parlamento
japonés